samedi soir à donetsk
l'alcool coule à flots la musique et m
on se croirait dans n'importe quelle
part de moscou les cette joie de vivre
elle n'est qu'éphémère les soirs de
week-end sont les seuls sans couvre feu
ici et bien sûr les gens profitent il
suffit de les écouter pour comprendre
qu'on est vraiment sur une autre planète
nous allons occuper cet orateur un
thonier dangereux ballon nous vivons
comme des otages du tanit comme des
apatrides qui personne ne sait vraiment
ce qui arrivera demain vous motiver les
grosses ou petites lignes aux jeunes à
tanger niveau est ce qu'on sera en
ukraine ou en russie
tout ce qu'on veut c'est vivre en
la paix est une notion bien ambiguë dans
ce no man's land au coeur de l'europe
une enclave isolée autoproclamée
indépendante de kiev par les forces
séparatistes la contrôler avec le
soutien indéniable de moscou quoi qu'en
dise le kremlin les couleurs de la
russie sont omniprésentes
ça fait des mois que notre équipe
attendait la permission des rebelles
pour entrer dans cette zone de conflit
absurde
autant le centre devenir épargner la vie
a repris
le centre de deux nièces ressemble
ressemble à n'importe quelle ville
européenne
autant les la périphérie il ya des gens
qui vivent constamment en souffrance
il faut bien connaître le terrain pour
s'aventurer hors de la zone urbaine
comme le fait régulièrement svetlana les
photographes qui revenue vivre dans son
donetsk natale pour documenter cette
guerre qui déchire son peuple depuis
à seulement dix kilomètres du centre
c'est la désolation
les tirs sont fréquents ils sont surtout
un prix visé
pour avoir le moral
et autres
zelensky je veux le déchirer en morpho
dix radars
en le regrettant presque aussitôt parce
qu'elle sait que d'autres côté les
enfants souffrent autant que les sens
mais c'est plus fort qu'elle
sa fille est née en décembre 2014 au
plus fort des combats ici dans la maison
elle raconte que l'ambulance n'a pas pu
venir à cause des tirs et c'est son papa
qui a coupé le cordon
la guerre devait finir l'année suivante
mais le cessez-le-feu signe à minsk est
constamment violés d'un côté comme de
l'autre dit christelle qui a choisi son
camp les gens se trouvent actuellement
en danger parce que les autorités
craignent refuse de reconnaître la
volonté populaire qui s'est exprimée en
2014 elle est une fermière club est tout
près de la ligne de francs de ce conflit
qui depuis huit ans a fait plus de 14
mille morts donc si on n'applique pas
l'accord de paix qu'est ce qui reste il
ne reste que la guerre
comme beaucoup de gens ici je me suis
fâché avec mes amis les membres de ma
famille parce que eux n'ont jamais voulu
voir la vérité telle qu'elle est
réellement ce qui pose lettres l'anah
christelle et tant d'autres ici une
résistance légitime est considéré par
l'ukraine une occupation illégale par
des terroristes armés jusqu'aux dents
par la russie
une milice populaire qui sous dirigé par
le commandant edward bas souligne qui a
reçu radio canada pour une rare entrevue
dans son quartier général
- patna chaigneau
les séparatistes
il pointe sur la carte les zones où ils
accusent l'armée ukrainienne de préparer
une provocation majeur est imminent
il dit que les forces craignant de
l'autre côté sont gavés d'armes comme
jamais grâce us ddp de l'otan mais il
nie avoir dans ses rangs des soldats
russes des mercenaires quand nous avons
demandé d'aller voir les soldats au
front la réponse a été non
ne sait plus qui croire sa seule
certitude c'est que l'enfance de sa
fille et foot
à 8 ans bêta c'est lire écrire mais
encore aujourd'hui elle ne sort que pour
aller à l'école et même en classe et
dont je vous laisse j'ai beau europe
l'atelier
criaq lorsque jacques chirac
à la banalisation de la normale et
bouleversante chez les enfants
[Applaudissements]
qui pour les retraités comme victor
c'est une faille de vie ainsi donc pour
ultime
jamais inscrits moe crohn pour gilbert
tout mauvais jours près de beni guil il
y à peine une semaine sa maison encore
été frappée
victory a échappé belle outre la russie
qui distribue des passeports il n'y a
aucune porte de sortie le panneau est
ce que je vais vous dire n'est pas
secret dit il la république de donetsk
ne pourra jamais survivre
les histoires de l'invasion russe de
l'ukraine là comme lady les médias
américains nous ont servis en mode
complètement hystérique c'est du grand
n'importe quoi et si vous demandez aux
gens d'ici
où est l'armée russe les gens vous
diront en rigolant que ça fait huit ans
qu'il les attendait qui les
accueilleront avec plaisir
[Musique]
oui
et dans l'adversité devant l'inconnu
m
story made in pissarev qui était un des
plus grands danseurs de ballet l'ukraine
brandit son art comme un drapeau blanc
il dirige le théâtre de deux nets depuis
bien avant la guerre mais il a décidé de
rester et offre des billets gratuits ou
plus éprouvés et
billy propice
cette paix qu'ils n'arrivent pas et qui
ne dépend plus d'eux
[Musique]